yeah it is going to be everyone's
favorite odd couple
it's not actually a couple snoop dogg
and
martha stewart doing the puppy bowl
it'll be on discovery's animal planet of
course it's at the same time as the
super bowl
so maybe if the game's not what you
wanted it to be
i can't imagine that because it should
be an exciting game just head on over
now remember we had our own
puppy bowl here at channel 8 just a
couple of years ago
and i got to be the referee and i think
we have some pictures
from how that went alex i don't know if
you were here with us back then
i wasn't but you know where i was before
we also had a puppy bowl
it was a lot of fun and all the dogs got
good homes
looks like you did a pretty good job of
keeping them in mind nate
well it was difficult because those
puppies have minds of their own
and then we had some extra humans in the
middle of the field including
john langler but i believe john if i
remember correctly we only had one
accident that needed to be cleaned up on
the field
yeah we had to throw a flag on that
situation but we managed to take care of
it